foreign
[Music]
[Music]
thank you
the population issue is not simply a
matter of numbers of people
it is also with increasing urgency the
need of those people for services which
Modern Life at any level demands
transport and housing schools and health
care
[Applause]
worldwide as people have come to
recognize the long-term Health and
Social implications of their own
fertility
and have begun to demand a reasonable
means to regulate that fertility a
compelling problem emerges
how to respond to that demand in a
manner which is appropriate to each
culture and respectful of each
individual within that culture
traditionally Family Planning Services
have been provided through clinics
couples seeking guidance and
contraceptives had to go to the clinic
regardless of the distance from their
home the inconvenience of the journey
the cost in transport or fees and the
sacrifice of inherent reticence access
to contraceptives has increased
dramatically when commercial outlets and
Village Supply Centers have shortened
the distance and simplified the
procurement process
household delivery aims to surmount
these barriers completely by placing
contraceptives in each household
containing an eligible couple
this final step in making supplies fully
available provides not only the best
possible initial information but
overcomes the obstacles of distance cost
inconvenience and lack of knowledge
within the last few years a number of
living Laboratories to test the validity
of taking contraceptives directly to the
people have been set up in countries
which offer a variety of unique problems
in Tunisia a basic problem was The
Presence at some distance from Urban
settlements of a substantial population
of eligible couples not normally reached
by Modern Health Care
the project recruited and trained
interviewers who not only collect
information but distribute oral
contraceptives
they visit every household in a defined
geographic area and offer contraceptives
to all eligible women eligible being
defined in Tunisia as under 45 years of
age currently married with husband
present not pregnant not known to be
sterile and with no Health
contraindications against pill usage
that
Project Director Dr Lilian Tumi
now
um
we thought that the best way to begin
was to choose girls from this region and
train them to talk to women
to explain the idea and methods of
Family Planning
we knew that the women here would have
more confidence in local girls who speak
the same language
and that they would listen to these
girls in this very personal Family
Planning program
let us watch a typical home visit in the
village of beer Ali in the province of
spax as Dr Toomey explains the rationale
behind it
we have arranged the work so that we
send the girls to their homes in groups
of two
they go to the homes talk to the women
and give them a supply of pills for six
months
they have been trained to explain fully
how to take the pills and what to do if
they have reactions or get sick we give
them a card and they can take it to the
clinic for examination by a doctor
if all goes well they can take the full
six-month supply of pills
before the supply is exhausted we will
come back to them in about five months
and again question them carefully and
report all that they say their reactions
and so on
and if everything is satisfactory we
will give the women another six months
Supply
the young visitor fills out all her
papers and has determined that the woman
is eligible then she begins to talk
I am giving you two packages of pills in
each package there are three smaller
packages
you open one of the packages five days
after you begin your period count
carefully one two three
four five
now on the fifth day at night
you start by taking this first pill the
white one you swallow this white pill
and you follow this line
taking one pill every night until you
finish this row
then you go back and start the second
row
then the next
and the next
these are the last you take
do you understand
yes
now if you should get signs of blood
while you were taking the white pills or
if you should not get the blood while
you are taking the red pills you had
better come to the doctor for an
examination
do I get the blood while I'm taking the
white pills
no you should get the blood only while
you are taking the red pills
when I get the blood do I come for
examination
only if you get it while you were taking
the white pills
but if you get it while you are taking
the red pills that is normal and you
don't need an examination
the pills will regulate your bleeding
fight means no blood
red means blood
do you understand
now suppose you want to stop taking the
pill because you want to get pregnant
again
don't just stop taking the pills
finish the cycle first then stop the
best way would be to check with us
another thing don't forget to take your
pills even for one day don't jump a day
it is bad for you and you might get
pregnant
now show me how you are going to take
the pills
so I can be sure you understand
this is the sort of careful interview
for which there is rarely time in a
crowded Clinic
and yet it is essential if a woman is to
understand and use the pill in a way
which will help her
in simple country terms it provides the
best sort of foundation for continued
use
foreign we will come back before the end
of six months now here is a card for a
doctor's examination if it is needed
Dr Toomey will be coming to the clinic
many times during the next six months
[Music]
put these packages away and keep them
out of the children's reach
don't start taking them until you get
your next period
another thing I want to say after you
start taking the pill you may get a
headache don't worry about it
it only happens because the pill is
something new you have not taken before
or you might get a stomach pain but if
you do don't throw away the pills go on
taking them you will be all right
we would not give you anything that
could really harm you
but if you get truly sick for any reason
then come to us
or send word to us so you can get an
examination by the doctor
now
take good care of yourself
and take care of the pills
take them with you wherever you go and
take them regularly
do you understand
foreign
now we leave you with God and if
anything goes wrong we will come back
and take you by car to the doctor
masri Shakir director of the national
family planning office sees the program
in Broad terms
foreign
we have promoted Family Planning
programs because we consider them
fundamental to the philosophy of family
well-being
they are part of a Humane consideration
of a way in which we can bring mankind
to a better level of Life With Dignity
a way to guard the health of mothers and
children
and to create truly healthy generations
for the future
this is our work
ultimate goal is to create healthier
generations of informed citizens we
consider that man is the most precious
Capital asset of the state
if we take care of him he can create the
national wealth indeed he is the wealth
with him we can achieve our aims of
development and progress
with the solid Assurance of full
government support Tunisia plans an
expansion of the household delivery
system into three more provinces with a
total population of more than 100 000
people
the pilot project grew out of the needs
and characteristics of the people
themselves truly an indigenous program
the expansion will capitalize upon the
findings of that project
[Music]
foreign
[Music]
Valley of the River Nile is Egypt's
Pride but the waters irrigate only a
limited area
97 percent of the nation's people are
crowded together on the four percent of
the land which is arable
giving it one of the world's greatest
population densities
people who are unconvinced by
demographic cries of Doom tend to point
to empty land areas as proof that
population can expand without penalty
but the cost of making desert land
habitable is enormous even the provision
of basic subsistence is expensive
[Music]
Egypt's population grows at the rate of
1 million a year with attendant pressure
on all public services
recognizing the special problem of a
population so concentrated the
government of Egypt has included family
planning in its Health Services
but the burden on these Services
demonstrates the need for supplementary
means of distribution if contraceptives
are to be made widely available
Dr Saad gadala has been active in
shanawan household delivery since it
began
he believes that it is essential to the
success of any such project that the
Whole Health Community be apprised of it
and when appropriate prepared to play a
supportive role
foreign
here he reminds health workers of the
importance the state attaches to Family
Planning and explains the plans to
expand household delivery to other
villages in their area
is an agricultural Village North of
Cairo the project began here is
elsewhere by sending a research team to
become acquainted with the village and
its people
our household distribution
in chanawan was certainly a success
when we started our research projects
in chennawan in 1969
the prevalence of contraceptive use was
four percent
through our efforts
in Family Planning communication
the percentage of contraceptive use
reached eight percent in 1972.
and we continued our work with the
family planning clinics and was
providing information about Family
Planning and contraceptives
until 1974
when in November 1974 the proportion
using contraceptive methods in the
village was 15 percent
we then did our household distribution
in November 1974
and in November 1975 the proportion of
contraceptive users increased to 31
percent
and this success
prompt us to expand the project
in 20
Health units serving 40 villages
with a population of 200 000 people in
Minnesota governorate
what I would really like to emphasize
is that our household distribution does
not conflict
with the present Family Planning
services in the clinic
it does not replace the present Family
Planning services in the clinic
but it enhances and supports these
services
the most important fact about household
delivery is that it works demonstrably
wherever it's been tried it works
to take the record of only four programs
and Egypt at the outset of the household
distribution program in shanawan
contraceptive prevalence was 15 percent
in one year this figure Rose to 31
percent
Korea had an active Family Planning
program before household distribution
prevalence was 30 percent
in only four months it had risen to 40
percent
foreign
distribution program began prevalence
was estimated at less than one percent
within one year the figure increased to
12.5 percent
in Tunisia the rate in the test area was
4.7 percent
within six months prevalence had risen
to ten percent
sort of experience represented by
projects which have been operative long
enough to be evaluated objectively
certain fundamental truths have emerged
contraceptives can be distributed to
households without serious adverse
incidents whether in urban Korea or
rural Tunisia
a packet of contraceptives in hand is
the most persuasive information tool
available
despite predictions to the contrary
contraceptives although free of charge
are perceived as valuable they may not
be used immediately
but they will be kept and used
eventually or given to Neighbors
and the leap and contraceptive usage in
every case is too dramatic to be
overlooked
worldwide experimental programs are
proving the correlation between
availability and acceptance
be it commercial distribution
Village Supply Centers
or household delivery the concept of
bringing contraceptives directly to the
people is a growing phenomenon around
the globe
the act of giving a woman the means of
controlling her fertility erases not
only the barriers surrounding
clinic-based Family Planning services
but also the differences of income
education
social level which have been thought so
important in acceptance rates
she holds in her hand something new
a little strange but not frightening
for the first time the hope of change
[Music]
foreign
[Music]
[Music]